tous les gens m'ont parlé bien entendu
de l'affaire de cette affaire et de ce
drame et tous les gens m'ont dit Cyril
on espère que cette personne ne va pas
être considérée comme folle ou
irresponsable puisque on le rappelle
Michel Marie cette personne est
considérée comme folle responsable elle
sera donc placée dans un dans un centre
psychologique qu'elle sera si les
psychiatres considèrent qu'elle est en
état de d'abolition de son discernement
elle ne peut donc pas être jugée et elle
est soignée placée dans un hôpital
psychiatrique et elle échappe en fait à
la justice
pour être placé sous la responsabilité
des médecins
alors
je me tourne vers George Fennec merci
Georges d'être avec nous c'est vrai que
vous aviez vous êtes un homme politique
un magistrat et vous êtes notamment
celui qui a porté la loi sur
l'irresponsabilité pénale pour cause de
troubles mental en 2008
cette loi ne doit pas changer
je vais vous répondre mais est-ce que
vous permettez d'abord de vous poser une
question bien sûr
pourquoi
abordons-nous comme ça collectivement
j'ai vu ça surtout les plateaux
l'irresponsabilité pénale de cette femme
quand savez-vous quand savez-vous que
son discernement était aboli jeunesse
c'est rien et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs parce que vous voyez on
s'engouffre comme ça dans une hypothèse
dans une question abominable ça peut
être comique que par quelqu'un qui
n'avait plus toute sa tête voyez-vous et
ben moi je ne suis pas d'accord je pense
qu'il faut être extrêmement prudent
attendre des expertises et je précise je
termine Cyril il y a eu déjà une
expertise en garde à vue mais qui a dit
que son état psychique était absolument
compatible avec la garde à vue et donc
c'est une bonne si on avait constaté
d'entrée qui avait un vrai problème
genre de schizophrénie paranoïa croyez
moi on l'aurait immédiatement transféré
dans un hôpital là ça n'a pas été le cas
pourquoi je vous dis donc prudence moi
je vous dis ça je vous dis ça Georges
voilà j'aime beaucoup
je sais qu'on s'entend bien tous les
deux c'est que on voit beaucoup
d'articles je lis beaucoup d'articles je
dis beaucoup de rapports et ils disent
tous qu'elle est déséquilibrée voilà que
ils disent voilà une personne plutôt
déséquilibrée donc c'est pour ça qu'on
joie tous les médias
prennent peur parce qu'ils disent est-ce
qu'ils vont pas nous jouer encore le
coup d'une personne irresponsable oui
Géraldine monsieur Fennec mais il est
responsabilité par exemple de l'assassin
de sarahimie puisque vous me dites là il
a été jugé on est d'accord donc il est
responsable il est où aujourd'hui cette
assassin il est dans un hôpital
psychiatrique et qu'est-ce qui fait dans
cet hôpital psychiatrique il regarde la
télé soit plus tard
il voit sa famille moi j'ai exactement
c'est exactement ce qu'on m'a dit ma
mère ce matin je suis pas certain qu'il
ait des permis ma mère m'a dit
qu'il a des permissions pas il mange il
dort et regarde la télé et voilà il se
fait soigner il fait soigner en plus et
donc c'est insupportable après George
mais c'est vrai que j'aurais beaucoup à
dire sur cette affaire oui je pense
qu'on moi je vais vous dire franchement
je pense que j'ai instruction ne pouvait
pas prendre la responsabilité à son
niveau de dire il y aura pas de procès
il y aura dû y avoir un procès et ça
aurait été à une cour d'assise avec un
jury de dire s'il avait la capacité
pénale ou pas vous voyez ce que je veux
dire je pense qu'on aurait pas dû on
aurait dû avoir un procès trop tard un
principe dans notre droit c'est qu'on ne
juge pas effectivement les fous on les
jugé au Moyen-Âge on jugeait les fous
les animaux même et vous donc c'est
comme ça c'est un grand merci beaucoup
et moi je vous savez comme je vous
respecte et comme je voilà je sais que
vous savez ce que je pense de vous je
vous dis aujourd'hui est-ce que
cette loi a toujours lieu d'être je suis
désolé moi on enlève les choses
incroyables et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
se dire un déséquilibré peut commettre
un meurtre et se retrouver comme à
digéraldine dans un hôpital
psychiatrique avec soigné manger
normalement
et alors que il a il a il a il a flingué
des familles entières c'est incroyable
cette loi elle est parce qu'en gros elle
permet à quelqu'un de commettre les
pires horreurs et de se cacher derrière
une folie et moi ce que j'aimerais
savoir c'est concrètement détermine
quelqu'un qui est fanamar est avec nous
et est-ce qu'une personne un sujet un
peu manipulateur ne peut pas berner les
enquêteurs et les psychiatres et se
faire passer pour un fou alors
psychologue ça c'est important comme
question oui
question question évidemment compliqué
puisque nous avons des antécédents qui
qui nous ont montré qu'on pouvait se
tromper donc évidemment la difficulté
d'autant plus importante que il s'agit
de juger d'un état de de non
discernement au moment des faits
donc par définition on n'était pas c'est
il y a une ambiguïté en effet entre se
poser la question d'une folie
structurelle présente installée et d'un
moment de folie
c'est là toute la difficulté alors
comment ça prend de temps cette
expertise
alors voilà sur un cas comme celui-ci
parce que voilà une vraie question en
général il y a plusieurs il y a
plusieurs même sont des collèges
d'experts
on commet 2 3 experts un autre collège
d'experts mais attention moi ce que je
tiens à dire aussi c'est pas parce que
ce crime est abominable
qu'il qu'il fait disparaître le
discernement je vous donne des exemples
regardez des tueurs en série comme
Michel Fourniret Guy Georges Patrice
Allègre par exemple ils ont tous été
condamnés reconnus coupable et pourtant
leur crime notamment ceux de Michel
Fourniret qui s'attaquait des petites
filles avec des rituels également
étaient abominable faut pas confondre la
maladie psychiatrique je passe sous
votre contrôle d'un psychopathe le
psychopathe sait ce qu'il fait mais
c'est la souffrance qu'il fait endurer
et il comprend le crime qu'il commet
vous alors je vous dis il y a une phrase
qui est ressortie hier et qui ressortit
même chez certains de nos confrères
c'est quand j'ai dit hier pour des
personnes comme ça parce que vous nous
parlez de d'experts voilà de gens qui
vont se réunir pour savoir si la
personne est responsable ou pas moi je
les ai dit et je le redis ce soir j'ai
pas peur de le redire pour ce genre de
personne pour moi le procès doit se
faire immédiatement c'est proser
immédiat c'est en quelques quelques
heures et terminer ces perpétuités
directes c'est de la démagogie c'est ce
que j'aurais fait oui je suis désolé
alors moi je pense que je connais dans
un débat de droit il y a des procédures
il a le droit à une défense pour moi n'a
pas le droit à une défense Barbie
ont été jugés avec des avocats ce qu'il
faut vivre avec son temps il faut vivre
avec son temps et aujourd'hui la société
a changé et on ne peut plus laisser des
gens comme ça être jugé pendant des
semaines et des semaines et ils sont
après dans un hôpital psychiatrique et
il reste trois quatre ans et après il
ressortent et la feuille et les victimes
la famille des victimes ce qui est
démagogiques c'est ce que vous dites
vous je suis désolé je trouve que ce qui
est beaucoup plus démo écologique ce que
vous dites vous que ce que je dis moi
pour moi c'est un procès immédiat et
direct c'est perpétuité c'est même pas
on discute même pas il y a pas de
discussion il existe ça devrait exister
je sais pas ce qu'on pense ici ça
s'appelle la loi du talion bah non pas
du tout alors je vais vous dire
ça s'appelle la loi ça s'appelle la loi
de la de je vous dis c'est c'est une loi
et c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
France les Français ils en ont marre ils
disent à chaque fois on se recueille on
est triste on se dit on espère que ça
reprendra pas et ça reprend parce qu'il
n'y a pas je vous le dis il n'y a pas
d'exemplarité il n'y a pas de de voilà
de de peine exemplaire
parce que l'histoire elle va durer des
semaines et des semaines et bah après
les gens vont oublier et puis après on
verra tiens d'autres filets ah bah tiens
elle a été placée ou truc ou bien
l'après je vous le dis aujourd'hui on ne
veut plus de ça je pense que ce qui est
magique c'est plus que vous dites-vous
et aujourd'hui ce que vous dites pour
moi je vous dis c'est plus audible pour
les pour les Français on en peut plus on
en peut plus d'entendre ça je voudrais
vous répondre c'est une France dépassée
sans esprit polémique vous l'aurez bien
compris
procès permet de toucher à la vérité un
procès ça permet de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé pour les parents mais les
parents ont besoin de savoir mais gardez
le procès des attentats du Bataclan ça a
duré 9 mois on a besoin de comprendre
vous jugez en 24 heures vous ne
comprenez pas ce qui s'est passé mais
écoutez l'instruction s'est fait pour ça
je suis pas d'accord la justice elle est
faite pour la manifestation de la vérité
ou alors on supprime l'institution
judiciaire du tout je suis pas d'accord
avec vous je suis d'accord il peut avoir
un procès pour la peine voilà immédiat
et ensuite après oui donner des éléments
aux parents et aux familles pour dire ce
qui s'est passé mais je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui je pense que franchement
énormément de Français sont d'accord
avec moi on n'en peut plus de cette de
ce laxisme juridique et de ce qui se
passe actuellement ça va encore durer
des mois et des mois elle va avoir un
avocat elle va pouvoir se défendre ils
vont plaider irresponsabilités ça marche
ou pas et ça va recommencer et il y aura
encore un autre problème aujourd'hui
pourquoi on fait pourquoi on parle de ça
encore aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on a
envie que ça n'arrive plus on en peut
plus de ça entièrement d'accord bah oui
mais c'est insupportable
et aujourd'hui bien sûr qu'il faut
prendre des mesures et aujourd'hui je
trouve que les lois ne sont pas adaptées
à la société actuelle je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez elle est en prison serrée
là elle est en prison
préventive
pourquoi il faudrait les protéger
pourquoi cette dame c'est ça l'envoyer
en prison c'est quoi l'intérêt
en prison il risque de ressortir les uns
et les autres à part quelques quelques
cas où on a la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité perpétuelle fournirait on
avait bénéficié si je puis me permettre
mais ils sont extrêmement rares ces cas
en France donc je voudrais vous dire une
chose
je vais peut-être un peu m'avancer
mais j'ai lu ici ou là des choses qui
m'ont interpellé
je rappelle que je me suis beaucoup
occupé des sectes professionnelle
qu'est-ce que je constate dans cette
affaire est-ce que ça me rappelle ça me
rappelle l'affaire des enfants des
urines vous connaissez les enfants qui
sont appelés au Maroc ou en Algérie des
souris c'est-à-dire qui sont considérés
comme ayant des pouvoirs généralement ce
sont des blonds yeux bleus qui ont des
caractéristiques morphologiques et ces
enfants souris il y a plein d'affaires
actuellement qui sont jugés en Algérie
c'est à c'est un vrai drame en Algérie
ils sont kidnappés ils sont sacrifiés on
boit leur sang il y a des rites
sataniques et sur cette pauvre fillette
il y avait le chiffre 1 sur la plante de
son pied gauche et le chiffre 0 et elle
a dit semble-t-il dans sa garde à vue
qu'elle avait bu son sang c'est
exactement le rite satanique des jurys
qu'on trouve en Afrique du Nord c'est
pour ça que moi j'ai besoin de savoir
qu'est-ce qui a inspiré cette femme
voyez bien sûr non mais ça on a on va
pas jugé comme ça en 24 heures il faut
comprendre mais encore une fois je parle
avec beaucoup de prudence je dis ça m'a
fait penser à cela non mais c'est vrai
que justement Michel Marie c'est bien
toujours je suis un mec on parle c'est
vrai qu'il y avait ces chiffres sur son
corps c'est c'est quoi c'était inscrit
sur ces deux pieds
au feutre rouge sur un pied il y avait
le chiffre 1 sur l'autre pied le chiffre
elle s'est à ma connaissance pas
expliqué sur ce sur ce point
c'est pas pour l'instant aujourd'hui il
y a de nouveaux éléments sur la présumée
coupable et sur ce qui s'est passé
puisque oui oui innocente
ce qu'on disait hier avec exactement
présumé innocente voilà
quels sont ces nouveaux éléments
en lien avec
son profil psychologique
des confrères on retrouvait le chauffeur
de Hubert le chauffeur uber chauffeur de
VTC qu'il l'a prise en charge
à Asnières pour la ramener sur les lieux
du crime et ce garçon raconte dans les
détails
c'est 20 minutes qui ont duré cette
course où ils à une femme à l'arrière
alors déjà il y a le chargement de de
cette fameuse caisse et des dealyses il
est il était aidé par
le le copain précédent le propriétaire
de la Dacia j'ai peur qu'on se perde un
peu dans mon propos mais essayez d'être
le plus clair possible
il charge donc cette cette malle ses
valises et Dabia repart avec ce
chauffeur VTC en direction des lieux du
crime c'est-à-dire dans le 19e rue Manin
[Musique]
et elle se mur dans un espèce de silence
pour un long moment encore de la course
et arriver devant le 119 rue Manin c'est
bondé de voiture de police puisque
depuis 15h il cherche Lola donc là il
est 23h je crois et on voit des voitures
de police partout on peut imaginer
qu'elles disent au chauffeur allez-y on
va on va plus loin et en fait dans son
esprit j'allais dire déranger
excusez-moi mais dans son esprit assez
particulier
elle demande au chauffeur de se garer
elle paye la course elle appelle sa
soeur au téléphone elle lui dit de façon
un peu vulgaire
descend décembre de [ __ ] et
la sœur descend
la soeur chez kill crimes s'est déroulé
quand même
et là il décharge cette cette malle qui
contient le corps de cette malheureuse
et là la sœur se doute quand même de
quelque chose et lui dit mais qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans la malle elle lui dit
écoute ça te regarde pas on va remonter
ça chez toi et du coup la sœur ne veut
pas la sœur refuse catégoriquement
rentre chez elle abandonne sa petite
sœur d'Abia sur le trottoir avec cette
main et ses valises et c'est là qu'elle
va se débarrasser du corps dans les
parties communes débarrasser de la malle
pardon dans les parties communes et
ensuite elle va rentrer en transport en
commun jusqu'à Bois-Colombes où elle
sera interpellée par la Brillette
criminelle le lendemain matin
je trouve quand même que le comportement
de cette femme après
on dirait ce que vous en pensez mais
comportement de cette femme est curieux
quoi alors l'ex-compagnon de la suspecte
s'est exprimé il a décrit quelqu'un de
dérangé
ensuite il a aussi expliqué que elle
était partie dans des questionnements
religieux particuliers dernièrement
qu'est-ce qu'il veut dire par là parce
que ça rejoint de ce que disait genre je
faisnec il y a un instant je m'interroge
beaucoup
s'interroger mais voilà comme tout le
monde et c'est vrai que ces chiffres il
y a eu un rite satanique voilà les
rapports sexuels les quasi égorgement un
nombre de coups de couteau important
tout ce que je viens d'écrire le sang
elle a bu elle l'a reconnu ça c'est pas
un crime ordinaire moi je n'ai pas le
souvenir d'un crime aussi abominable
dans toute ma carrière d'habitude les
femmes elles sont les complices de leur
mari dans les crimes abominable Monique
Olivier était l'accomplisse de Michel
Fourniret l'affaire Dutroux vous
souvenez mais là appelle l'auteur
principal on voit des femmes tuer leur
enfant mais c'est des infanticides ça
n'a rien à voir là c'est un massacre un
rituel vraiment un massacre je n'ai
jamais vu ça de toute ma carrière j'ai
cherché j'ai cherché je n'ai pas trouvé
de précédent c'est vraiment un crime qui
dépasse tout ce qu'on a pu connaître
justement Georges
Michel il y a un autre témoin qui évoque
une scène où la suspecte aurait crié il
l'a fait au téléphone comme si elle
était possédée oui un témoin qui dit ça
effectivement mais alors là encore
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut dire de quoi elle
parle
sur qui veut-elle jeter un quelconque
discrédit je n'en sais rien une fois de
plus
je pense qu'elle est elle a un vrai
problème elle est vrillée quoi donc tout
ça n'est pas cohérent si vous voulez
donc nous on écarte les uns on essaye de
de d'analyser de de de
décortiquer des comportements qui sont
pas cohérents
[Musique]
enlever les pardon oui elle servait
d'appât elle a abordait les enfants pour
les faire monter dans la voiture et
quelques fois il y a même son fils qui
était sur le siège arrière donc la
qualité de femme à mon avis a suffi pour
il y a pas une grande distance en plus
aujourd'hui on imagine bien entendu le
désarroi des parents de la famille de de
Lola et il y a une question qui revient
c'est
est-ce que on va changer des choses
après ça c'est vrai que c'est la
question qui revient très souvent parce
que est-ce qu'on va prendre des
nouvelles mesures est-ce que les lois
vont changer parce que c'est vrai qu'il
faut redire que police et vous l'avez
dit a été extrêmement
elle a très bien fait son travail
puisque ça a été réglé vous parlez
à l'heure où il est question de réformer
la police judiciaire je pense que il
faut pas y toucher parce que
ça fait exactement ils sont saisis à
minuit et à 7 heures du matin interpellé
l'auteur ils ont trois autres garde à
vue donc ils ont fait un travail
absolument remarquable il y a rien à
dire là-dessus je suis d'accord avec
vous quand vous dites que les lois elles
doivent évoluer en fonction de
l'évolution de la société de la
criminalité etc c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle en 2008
effectivement c'était sous quinquennat
Nicolas Sarkozy Rachida Dati était
ministre et moi j'étais rapporteur de
cette loi on a réformé cette question
des jugements des irresponsables
qu'est-ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
lorsque je me souviens avant cette fois
j'étais une instruction quand on
constatait l'état de démence le juge
rendait une ordonnance de non-lieu
vous imaginez dans la tête des victimes
la famille encore ça veut dire il s'est
rien passé c'est fou il n'y a pas lieu
mais c'est rien passé donc c'était
traumatique le non-lieu c'est-à-dire il
y a pas lieu quoi voilà poursuivre alors
ce qu'on a fait en 2008
on a institué quand même une un mini
procès devant la chambre d'instruction
ou les magistrats en présence des
parties en présence des avocats des
experts et si possible donc de
l'intéresser qui se trouve dans le box
on constate la matérialité des faits
c'est-à-dire l'imputabilité des faits
c'est bien cette personne qui a bien
commis matériellement se crée ça c'est
une chose très importante la
reconnaissance de l'auteur du crime et
après on constate parce que les experts
nous le disent que cette personne est
totalement irresponsable elle a une
paranoïa aiguë une schizophrénie aiguë
elle a perdu tous sens de facultés
intellectuelle et donc à ce moment-là la
chambre d'instruction qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait elle rend un arrêt de constatation
de l'irresponsabilité et elle place la
personne dans un établissement qui peut
être un UMD une unité pour malade
difficile sans possibilité de sortir
un problème avec la loi aujourd'hui
c'est que les avocats de la défense ont
très bien lu la loi et beaucoup entre
dès le départ et c'était l'inquiétude de
Cyril ça rapport à ce drame c'est que
l'avocat qui n'est pas très loquace mais
lui risque peut se servir de tout ça de
tous ces éléments de d'une personnalité
éventuellement dérangée pour aller vers
les responsabilités c'est beaucoup
d'avocats mise là-dessus aujourd'hui la
question au tout début pourquoi vous
entamez déjà ce débat des
responsabilités on n'en sait rien parce
que les avocats le font vous c'est le
rôle des avocats mais nous faut qu'on
soit prudent
que c'est une possibilité
en quoi le fait d'être fou ça change les
choses en quoi c'est la tenue la gravité
des faits Lola elle est partie quoi
qu'il arrive c'est le tueur soit fou ou
non de toute façon
dites-moi les personnes vous voulez
faire quoi les ampoules rétablir la
peine de mort non vous voulez faire quoi
normalement mais ils sont dans des
hôpitaux fermés mais
vous avez soulevé
je les condamne les fous peut-être même
même plus quelqu'un qu'un normal
peut-être que je me dis lui il était fou
il est en liberté il a rien fait à
partir du moment où qui brille ça y est
c'est fini pour moi il ressort plus il
reste enfermé jusqu'à la fin de séjour
j'ai pas envie en prison il faut les
soigner
les amis les amis c'est un soignable
quelqu'un qui s'amuse à égorger à violer
à mettre des numéros sur les pieds des
gens c'est vous les soigner quoi on
parle d'où on part de des millénaires et
les parents
je ne veux pas les voir avec moi en
société c'est terminé
et moi j'ai plein d'histoires de femmes
parce que j'ai plein d'histoires de
femmes qui ont été faire un jogging qui
ont été tués j'ai plein d'histoires de
Marie qui ont tué leur femme dans la
forêt qui les ont brûlé j'ai plein
d'histoires de petites filles qui ont
été jugées
il ressortiront dans 10 ans vous le
savez très bien
français nos enfants comment on fait
pour se protéger d'abord de nous et
comment 7 pour se protéger de gamins 10
ans qu'on rien demandé qui rentre de
l'école qui se font égorger qui se font
mettre dans des mâles déplacer de droite
à gauche et vous c'est quoi c'est quoi
le truc ah il est fou ah bah c'est pas
de sa faute il est fou non non tu
ressors plus jamais
la vraie après ça existe
mais rien n'est fait
et vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la peine
de mort mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on se
bouche à chaque fois les oreilles parce
que au bout d'un moment effectivement
les crimes et les criminels changent on
a des terroristes on a des gens qui
récidivent et tout faites une fois un
sondage et on va voir ce que pense
vraiment les Français et ça aussi c'est
une rencontre
petit à petit au fur et à mesure je
pense que ça va encore une fois changer
donc il faut il faut vraiment que la
France change et excusez-moi pareil avec
tout le respect que je vous dois
donc vous êtes vous êtes donc à l'instar
de cette loi
l'initiative voilà à l'initiative donc
aujourd'hui si l'arrivée quelque chose à
un membre de votre famille est-ce que
vous seriez consolé néanmoins si on
disait que la personne était juste jugée
irresponsable parce que parfois on a
l'impression que ces personnes là qui
font ces lois vous êtes débranchés vous
êtes hors sol vous pouvez pas comprendre
les familles et quelque part je me dis
si la personne est folle pour tuer et
ben elle s'en rendra pas bien compte si
elle ira en prison donc à la rigueur au
bout d'un moment
de dire ça
je vous pose la question si ça vous
arrive est-ce que vous seriez
satisfait et enfin pas satisfait mais
disons de se dire la réponse est cette
personne a été folle donc du coup on ne
la juge pas mais c'est pas une réponse
pour les familles et c'est pour ça que
cette loi là pour moi
oui c'est de votre esprit
la psychiatrisation ça existait du temps
du Goulag mais on soviétique la seule
chose que je peux vous dire c'est qu'il
n'y a pas une seule démocratie au monde
qui juge des irresponsables pénaux des
malades mentaux ça n'existe pas et si
vous avez l'occasion d'aller d'efforts
c'est pas vrai elle ne dites pas ça non
non mais allez voir dans les prisons ce
qui se passe vous allez voir mais depuis
avant on parle de la psychologie de
qu'est-ce qu'elle a voulu dire quel est
le message quel est l'oeuvre de
l'artiste mais en fait on s'en fout
parce qu'une petite fille est morte et
il faut répondre concrètement avec vous
un procès c'est fait pour que le le
condamné comprenne ce qui lui arrive
comprenne sa peine et éventuellement
elle ne comprendra pas puisqu'elle est
folle donc ce sera pas mieux à l'hôpital
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu un vrai fou
moi j'en ai vu moi
ils sont jamais passés à l'acte mon
deuxième lui il est ouf
un vrai fou ouais c'était des vrais fous
il se faisait interner il était à
l'hôpital l'humouriot deuxième étage à
Colomb c'est l'hôpital pour les fouilles
rentrer l'après-midi
la question tu as dit qu'il fallait
juger un fou expliquez-moi pourquoi faut
pas le juger alors qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait on le met dans un autre on le
souhaite alors il comprend il comprend
alors il faut le choix mais on comprend
de commettre des crimes des crimes
atroces mais il comprend pas il comprend
un VTC il comprend il faut appeler des
gens et comprendre faut aller chez son
papa il comprend pas qu'il faut revenir
dans le 19e
tu peux me permettre
on comprend qu'il y a beaucoup
d'émotions
une énorme envie collective de
justice de cadre qui nous rassure etc ça
évidemment on le ressent tous parce que
quand même sentiment que notre société
va mal elle-même société devient folle
moi je crois que je le dis plusieurs
fois en ce moment régulièrement le monde
devient dingue
donc évidemment on amène ça mais du coup
il faudrait pas non plus nous même que
ça nous fasse tourner la tête c'est à
dire au sens
c'est la politique française là en
l'occurrence ce que je voulais dire
c'est que
on se met à dire les fous
qu'est-ce que c'est les fous
et c'est toutes les questions
c'est-à-dire qu'à partir de quand et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est frontière en
effet la société évolue cette frontière
aujourd'hui elle pose de plus en plus
question
il faut agir au cas par cas mais qu'une
personne qui a commis rien comme ça elle
est jugée
folle voilà c'est voilà c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a fait la réforme maintenant il
y a plusieurs plusieurs
faut-il juger les fous oui à 86% non à
13%
[Applaudissements]